money's not gonna make me happy I'm fine
where I am
I'm doing better than people that live
in Afghanistan none of that makes sense
if you had the potential to make more
money if you don't call me back I'm
gonna go ahead and ship this out to you
today all right you got to know how to
practice okay so this is what we're
gonna do
Juanes or get a mentor what's up belief
nation it's Evan I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so today
let's learn from one of the best grant
cardone and how to master the art of
selling mentor me grant also if you want
to know a grant cardone and others have
to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below you have to go
build self-confidence
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one get your money mindset right first
thing you got to get right if you want
to be in the sales game today is you got
to get your freakin financial literacy
right you got to get your money
financial mindset right you got to start
thinking about taking your finances from
the level you are to the level where you
and your family deserve to be and you
know this is true
okay people that are not making enough
money simply make sense of why they're
not making enough money money's not
gonna make me happy I'm fine where I am
I'm doing better than people that live
in Afghanistan okay well none of that
makes sense if you have the potential to
make more money if you have a great
product a great company and you know
another call another strategy one more
little maybe angle something that you
could persist with if you know that you
could be making more money and you
aren't
let's get that fixed okay and the first
thing to becoming a millionaire a
multi-millionaire I hacked a millionaire
or a billionaire and I've spent time
with enough billionaires now is they
have made decisions to get their money
right okay whether they're going public
or selling a product scaling out they
had to make a decision to get the money
the finance model of their household
their business their product or their
IPO right right if they want to go to
the market and become a public company
so number one get your money right it's
not about product knowledge first it's
not about sales now it's first it's not
about sales process first it's not about
to follow up first or right in the
customer up first it's not even about
attitude first it's about get your
financial mental get your money mental
right okay because if you're satisfied
if you're happy where you are
financially why would you sell anything
else look let's face it you're on
Commission you get paid to sell things
you get paid to close deals you get paid
to follow up only when it works okay
number one get your money mindset right
rule number two get attention when I
started Twitter account I had no
followers when I started Facebook
account no followers
I was my first follower when I started
Instagram account no followers I didn't
know how to post video I didn't know how
to take a selfie I didn't know how to do
any of this but I did have a commitment
to grow in my finances and if you want
to grow your finances attention is the
gateway you want to go to heaven who
wants to go to heaven you got to die
just telling you man you got to die to
go to the heaven and most people don't
want to die they want to go to heaven
but they don't wanna die most people
want money but they're not willing to
get the attention they're not willing to
do what it takes to get the attention
including spending money and I would
just tell you this if you want to change
your financial condition the first thing
you need to do is go out and market in
the marketplace so that you can create a
lead and not worry about whether there's
ROI or not it's so stupid that people
like what's the ROI do what's the ROI if
nobody knows you okay what's the ROI if
I don't know your name don't know your
company don't know what you do don't
know your service don't know your
product don't know where you're located
what is the ROI okay best product does
not win today the best known product
wins so if you're taking notes write
this down best known product wins it
always has won best car doesn't win the
best automobile doesn't win hey what
happened to the Volvo because it's a
Volvo you know safe in full control of
its power oh is the safest car the
safest car that nobody has
right but it's the safest you think
starbucks sells the best coffee please
nasty okay but it's closed and I know
what I'm getting when I get there
McDonald's sit let's sell the best
Hamburg clothes and available rule
number three mix up your strategies
number three you got to mix up you got
to mix up your strategies it can't just
be one strategy you're no longer just a
phone person or an in-person person or
an Internet person if you're heavily
dependent upon the internet do not
abandon your other mixed choices this is
like mixed martial arts we call it mixed
martial selling that's right
mixed martial selling I am the mixed
martial arts of sales because I use the
phone I use the internet I use social
different than the Internet and number
four I use a personal visit
I will walk in knock on your door and
number five I use referral so what are
your different mixed martial arts if you
will you're mixed arts of sales today
the Internet's one the phone's one
retail traditional retail visits for
social media and number five referrals
influencers getting other people to
endorse you rule number four practice
you got to know how to practice okay so
this is what we're gonna do
which one of these three do you want to
handle right now let's go with the price
design I feel like I'm on The Price is
Right pick the objection son let this
let your people pick the one they're
having trouble with yeah so you give me
a price I'm gonna give you the objection
okay so it's gonna be we get your
property service it's gonna be a hundred
twenty bucks every every three weeks
that's ridiculous
no I understand yeah so what do you
understand if you understand and then
fix the price okay okay listen I
understand price too high I get it
look let's do it anyways that's it's
weird
but why would I do it anyway when the
price is too high right listen I
understand you know help me understand
you know how houses probably the salty
problem you guys are great it's a flop
but dude he's trying so what we got to
do is keep working with Miss like Elena
going to kick she's not gonna kick very
hard the first time right you're
shooting a gun you're working with the
gun you're scared of it you're terrified
of he's never had a gun in your hand
who's scared of guns people that don't
have them right put one in your hand you
play with it bull dude that felt good
that felt strong yeah next thing you are
oh okay okay okay man the price is 119 a
month let me tell you what we did for
you before you object anything okay see
I'm controlling this I'm gonna control
this guy before you say yes or no let me
tell you what we do for you I just wear
mine sure yeah I don't have 119 for this
I understand you don't expect you to pay
119 if you don't have it but what you do
have is you have mosquitoes right and
let me tell you the downside of
mosquitoes this a is a commercial
enterprise you got customers come over
here they leave your grocery store and
they get bitten by mosquitoes okay you
know what happens now they don't
remember the service they don't remember
your commitment they remember that's the
place that brought my kids they got to
Zika
now let me just say this about the 119
if you'd like to pay it weekly it would
only be $30 a week and we take Visa
Mastercard or maybe we do some kind of
barter system with your grocery store
smile
I'm smiling the whole time I'm
controlling things I don't let him talk
too much right because I know everything
that's gonna come out of his face right
now he's preparing to object for me I
want to I want to make sure he doesn't
do a lot of that what do you think yeah
I don't know i'ma have to take it back
to it other than yourself other than
your self Oh see now what we found out
what it was right it's the boss what if
your boss says no what do we do then oh
well I don't know I don't know what to
do I mean if they say no I mean I guess
it's not gonna be no right right but why
did you agree to meet with me today cuz
we got mosquitoes you got mosquitoes man
then you check in with the boss they
just come in right okay okay yeah now
let me ask you something is the boss of
real thing no could you do this not well
yeah I could probably do it so you guys
don't ask hard questions man it's the
boss the real thing man you just put me
off you just playing me off right now
cuz it'll 1:19 once y'all ask people
that yeah okay you want it you want to
take a different one yeah okay I'm
calling the guy I'm calling the guy hey
hey man I want to come over I'm gonna
give you an estimate on the Zika
protection all right I'm gonna come over
I'm going to show you how to never have
another mosquito at your place again and
so it was this little cause I'm not
interested yeah I'm not I'm not if so
yeah I'm not if I'm gonna do it to you
but I want to know how you're gonna
handle that
okay okay all right so you're calling me
it's a coke yeah listen I'm just trying
to call you and you know so I can I give
it a your mosquitoes oh that's good man
that's good you got me that's how you
get rid of mosquitoes man yeah listen
listen what we can do is uh you know
it'll cost about 120 bucks for us to get
rid of your mosquitoes so that's good
man send me a proposal
so you're opposed it sure so weird says
you I was in it send it to my office
just got my address
yeah matter of fact let me send it to
your office but let me get your number
let me text message you see he did the
number thing it'll blow up in his face
every time which I got my number man you
already got my number man don't be
stupid man cor now you went off into
space okay try to get that was a flop
all right yeah I'm not interested you
did a good up down not interested I'm
not interested no I understand
completely
listen um you know let's just go ahead
and do it anyways you [ __ ] him right
here
pick him back up to where I just said
hey look I'm not I don't I don't see me
it proposes but okay that's where he got
stumped by the way you just go back and
you pick it up where he he flunked he
did good on the first part of the call
he got me to the place where I said send
me a proposal and pass not interested
send me a proposal man okay uh let me
get that uh let me get your email so I
can go ahead and since you [ __ ] send me
a proposal I love to our lovely sin the
proposal yeah yeah gotta keep you have
to keep I love this in the proposal yeah
let's go ahead and that's a great idea
man by the way I've already sent one in
your email by the way how many of you
could send somebody an email before the
call was even finished and I already
have it sitting there directions
locations confirmations a place to text
you in case you can't make it okay
get this man a big hand huh come on
so we got on the road again would it wit
farm you know what if I can go ahead and
take care your mosquitoes for free oh
he's coming up now he's coming up with
some stuff how many even come up with
good ideas after the deal is done rule
number five control the communication
number five be logical and structured in
the call I have to have a structure in
the call otherwise your people go all
over the place and run out of time be
respectful be enthusiastic be memorable
how do you sell yourself on a phone call
what's your tonality what's your voice
like if you're an introvert how do you
get your people out of that introversion
and become interesting enough to grab
entertain be memorable be entertaining
enough and how do you use third-party
third-party data credible information to
set yourself apart from everyone else
I'll give you one little trick real
quick did you know that if I have a
headset on and I'm taking a phone call
I want my mobile phone in this hand
because I want to text to that customer
that prospect the person asking for
questions I want to text them during the
call it improves your chance at an
appointment by 500% and your chances of
closing a deal by 328 percent by merely
saying can i text you some data while
you're asking the best price or our
proposal or the warranty or you'd like
to see what this products made of or
what the FDA said about this or that I
can text that to you right now
texting during an actual phone call will
increase your appointment ratio your
appointment show ratio and ultimately
bring a cash register and then scripts
okay
scripts your people need scripts they
need a format to run off of in order to
control a communication your people are
having conversations conversations are
not selling controlled communications
start change the conversation hook the
customer in create enough interest being
entertaining and memorable use
third-party data and then close how do I
close when do I quit selling and start
closing it's about control
a communication not having a
conversation rule number six
be creative never ever send a text or an
email with confrontation in it it will
never ever work never in my damn life
has a text message to somebody
challenging them ever been successful
and then they're always a great thing
you guys can start sounding kind of
slimy with like like yeah yeah I got it
yeah yeah I got it yeah yeah I got it
but you're not really listening to the
guy you get you've got to acknowledge
the communication the full
acknowledgement of the communication is
I understand that it's not the right
time you've got to acknowledge that and
then return back to the problem you
can't keep banging you cannot Triforce
for these people it's not gonna work us
okay so so you got to figure out other
creative ways to go about the other
influencers somebody else an
organization somebody on LinkedIn that
knows them a referral you got to figure
out some other creative ways other than
just being the caveman that comes out
with a what a club and tries to you know
beat the baby seal up you got to think
about a smarter way to I wouldn't work
on fishing I can't do it with fishing
right what do I do I throw out some
other bait man are not taking this bait
I throw other bait out I gotta figure
out another lure I gotta get creative or
I got to fill my pipeline up it's a
big-ass ocean out there so I don't want
you guys banging on somebody so hard
that they're like hey man quit calling
me right quit calling me means you still
a long time ago this is way beyond
okay this is you you dropped creativity
and professionalism about 12 calls
before this I always say no one thing
will blow a deal that does not mean
seven different things can't blow a deal
so if you're on a call and you know
you're not getting anywhere man
like there's no hey man dude I'm not
interested I'm not a player you can feel
your pipeline up and don't be lazy right
fill the pipeline up go back to work
right never rely on one source for
anything that means when a call goes bad
I'm like Jarrod that call went awful how
many of you did that yesterday
that call was terrible this guy hates my
guts please Todd called them for me how
many of those were done yesterday zero
there is impossible impossible that you
guys were not bad on a call yesterday
raise your hand if you were terrible on
a call yesterday good what do you why
wouldn't you turn that over why wouldn't
you go to Todd say dude I was terrible
in that called man can you fix it for me
can you can you soften up this thing for
me I've had my wife new calls for me in
real estate deals
maybe call this guy right now and say
hey what you know what grant really
wants this deal what can we do to put it
back together and rule number seven the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is up your skills okay so I start
calling people right now what I got to
do to do business with you that's all I
want to know dude you guys aren't making
that phone call every day if you're not
doing this it's because you don't have
the skills and what happens is your fear
your fear gets big okay your fear gets
big you got so much fear why because
your fears higher than your skills your
skills are down here and your fears up
here what the more skills I get the more
my fear goes down what you want to do is
you want to educate learn training
prepare practice read scripts you want
to immerse yourself into life your name
balance more still kill more kill more
skill than fear you're always gonna have
a little bit of fear mark boy grant
cardone call me back right away three
one zero seven seven seven oh two five
man I got something look hey if you
don't call me back I'm gonna go ahead
and ship this out to you today all right
coming back now you see that's the way
to get people to call you back so they
do the final you're back I'm shipping
now I've got a special bonus clip with
grains on how to master your craft but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one what
skills do you need to up number two how
can you practice selling more and number
three what new attention-grabbing
strategy can you apply this week
is the sales department okay i'ma blow
in on the sales department and show them
how to sell something that's gonna
increase morale it's gonna drive revenue
it's gonna make the business successful
that's what people all over the world
are not doing this is a guy on the phone
right now his hairy trumpet for
everybody to know Bielema drop in not
discuss belly flop be honest why not you
this I'll give you a call at the end of
the month it was born in with me see
where we're at at CVX let me have that
off really this is Carlos hey Carlos hey
grant cardone here how you doing this is
you talking to me right now
hey and the reason I'm jumping on this
call Carlos is because I heard Jerrod
say something about he's gonna call you
back next month okay but let me ask you
something why did you look at it in the
first place okay so what's important to
you and Carlos excuse me but do you feel
like you're missing opportunities right
now so you didn't call Jared you didn't
show interest in our product because you
wanted to save money you call a chair
because you want to increase your income
be raised by your revenue by
having your people better handle
situations get your veterans experience
and get your green your newer
salespeople training well the 1500 a
month that that's your objection is the
cost yeah well let me explain to you
that it's not 1500 a month it's thirty
six thousand dollars is it yourself plus
the four thousand dollar startup fee
which means it's 40 thousand I need you
to think about a forty thousand dollar
decision not at $1,500 a month decision
you're gonna be on this program two
years not one month if you're not going
to be only two years you need to tell me
that upfront because then we don't need
to do it it won't work anyway
let me ask you a question Carlos I will
Suze when's the last time your company
spent forty thousand dollars a huge have
you ever had it not work right so look
you're going to spend forty thousand
dollars to train your people over two
years over two years to handle every
opportunity it comes to you and you
spend four hundred and eighty thousand
dollars in the same period of time on
advertising this represents basically
eight percent of your ad budget do you
want to train your people do you want
them motivated if so if you're going to
do this sooner or later
if you're going to do this sooner or
later and I'm going to suggest and
that's why I'm getting on the call take
time out of the equation and let's do
this the reason I got on the call was to
assure you that I'm here to support you
and help you
look Carlos Carlos I appreciate your
business well that's what everybody
should be doing right now to make
businesses work so they survive and
prosper
what's your what's your home address I
want to send you something personal for
me you got horses
what was it what's the zip code again I
missed it okay good
do you have any do you have any concerns
about doing this yeah that's right we're
gonna be right would there be any reason
you would change your mind I'm sending
it to you right now thank you so much
for your business and look look for your
mailbox look in your mailbox for a so
special okay thank you
so si want this Luke it's not always
gonna work like that but if the
executive drops in brings in the
altitude brings in the enthusiasm even
if I would have failed I restore my
sales department they see that I'm
watching they see that it's happening
now they see success
if you want more sales tips check out
the video we did on how to master the
art of selling with Jordan Belfort the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there great salespeople
understand that it takes three four or
five noes to actually get to the yes